[Music]
[Applause]
hey they are welcome to awesome comics
your one-stop shop for everything comic
book entertainment I am your host this
week Ayanna Wade welcome back to all of
you regular viewers and welcome to any
of the new ones we have out there I'm
going to go ahead and introduce our
guests with us today to my right is hi
I'm how the roof and are you excited to
be talking about Watchmen today you know
I am it is one of my favorite graphic
novels and I have a lot of things to say
about the movie a lot of things awesome
good that's what we're here for and then
to my left Brian Porter so are you
excited to be talking about that today
we all know how much I love talking
about Zack Snyder yes that's true
speaking of Walter actually can't be
with us today I apologize about that but
we were really worried about the weird
paradox that might happen of him being
Zack Snyder and talking about Watchmen
it's just too much to get into all right
but we're going to get into it this
week's topic is obviously as you know
since you clicked on the link a watchman
and we're very excited to discuss the
movie and some controversial stuff some
people like it some people don't like it
so we have two opposing sides this week
and Heather yeah you're going to go
ahead and start us off with our first
topic we're going to be talking about
characters and the acting what do you
like what don't you like okay well first
of all I'm outside of not necessarily
liking it because like I said earlier
the graphic novels on my favorite
graphic novels I love it so I have some
issues with the characters especially
with I don't even know what it is it
feels like even though they have some of
the characters verbatim from the book
there is just something missing there's
a piece of them that missing that's
missing that is sacrificed for them just
being cool like don't get me wrong
Rorschach is incredibly a cool character
he's interesting to watch but there is
still a piece of his dimension of his
character that I feel like is missing
and I especially feel that with Adrian
and I husband as it does thank you I
read it more than I said I'm sorry
because I feel like in the movie they
just make him a dick he's just a
straight-up dick rich guy who was like I
know everything let me tell you why I
can rule the world but he got more of a
human element to him in the graphic
novel all of them do feel like there's a
humanity element that's missing that
just didn't translate Mulford me and do
you think that's more directing or they
acting choice for some of them it's
acting so I feel like some of silk
spectres headlines fault were flat or
there's a couple of times where it just
seems like she's not even acting at all
same was night oh they have some really
odd chemistry that's supposed to be
strong obviously they get together they
hook up but there's again something
that's missing and some of their
deliveries just fell super flat sure
reporter so far I was cool with with the
characters I mean I I liked the movie
shocking that I was either gonna do but
every guy's crazy
I actually liked the movie I didn't
really have too much that I didn't like
about it but I've never read Watchmen I
flipped through it some of the stuff
looks like it's paid for page panels of
the screen and that's cool but I don't
actually like the art of the book so
that's why I've never read it and I know
yeah yeah die die die slide a little bit
so we're short a palm yeah but the
characters like for the most part I
thought they were pretty good I mean
Ozymandias seemed a little stiff and
stilted but that could have been because
he's supposedly this genius age should
be very eccentric sure Rorschach I
thought was an awesome character I mean
I feel like he had a decent mount of
depth for someone who was so mysterious
and you know cloaked in mystery and I
just thought that they delved into him
as much as they could for that type of
character and I'm even later on when
they take his mask off like give me back
my face and it kind of showed like how
he identifies as a person as Rorschach
instead of his you know his real
identity kind of like holds Batman Bruce
Wayne it was easy guys I like Jackie
Earle Haley I thought he was a badass in
the film so I really liked him
a lot of people love that monologue I
was also invited many made it was very
cool I'll give you $9 for the most part
I liked him as a character but he seemed
a little awkward a lot especially with
Silk Spectre and I was like I don't know
if this is just him or if they're trying
to do this as like his awkward chemistry
beauty kind of like Silk Spectre or
whatever and you know Malin Akerman her
she was pretty good for the most part
but yes she did fall flat but overall
the characters I was fine with but you
know the comedian I thought was great I
mean Jeffrey Dean Morgan we all know
it's insane and he plays insane well and
I thought he was really cool the carla
Gugino or however you say last name the
first Silk Spectre I thought she was
pretty good she's a great actress and
then what's the dr. manhattan's that
that's his name right yeah for the type
of character that he was I thought they
they they captured what the mind of
someone who would experience that type
of thing
you know how would devoid of emotion or
then and to tell ya how they would deal
with it in fact that he didn't go
instantly insane and kill everybody was
kind of like okay cool you're handling
it pretty well I'd say I know a lot of
people had issues of him being like so
blank-faced but I know a lot of that is
animation some of it too is so it did
not hold off why I got up is amazing but
also I understand that as a character
he's supposed to be very stoic right but
that watching it for a long period of
time got boring for some people so yeah
it was a long movie for sure but there's
a lot of exposition to get through
though yeah I mean obviously look at the
size of the grant first of all like this
also went through a few different
directors and training teams and stuff
that talked about it and it were amazing
even got a movie out of this because
they talked about it needing to be a
miniseries and stuff oh yeah much
information and stuff right you're going
to miss them so yes we got a long movie
that's what we got out of it and there's
even alternate cuts so these and longer
cuts as well I've never cared to watch I
actually haven't seen the extended cuts
there - so I just watched it in theaters
and rewatched it again and yeah remember
seeing
and in theaters that was a pretty big
pretty big deal to finally see it on
screen
we're going to be moving on to our next
topic a little more controversial I know
a lot of people have issues slash loved
the sex and violence in this movie and
so that's kind of a hot topic so ordered
you want to start us off were you or how
they handle it or I mean granted I don't
really know how they handle the
relationships in the sex and violence in
the book I assume that the book is very
violent but the sex I mean it might have
been a little less graphic or whatever
but I mean it's Hollywood they
over-sexualize things all the time so it
wasn't like shocking for me to see oh my
god they're banging what and it's like
okay this is Hollywood they're trying to
bring in audiences and they're going to
over-sexualize it sure that's nothing
new
so I didn't care one way or the other I
thought the fire blastin the ship at the
end was really funny I'm laughs it had
been in the comics the family laughs I
thought it was hysterical I didn't like
the way all lit that's interesting but
the violence I mean they seem like
violent characters and violent times
so especially Rorschach and I was fine
with it I thought like they might have
seemed a little overpowered for people
who don't actually have powers yes I was
I I was under the assumption that they
had powers like the first time that I
watched the movie because of how much
you guys were flying all over the place
and they know compositing yeah but I was
like okay the superheroes maybe they're
just really good at this stuff so was I
was as masked vigilante is that I was
fine with it it didn't seem excessive
like there didn't really seem like oh my
god like you know with the walking dead
and how people are so like the blood and
guts of the season-opening like it was
nothing like that it's just like beating
the out of each other a lot but it
didn't seem excessive like okay I wasn't
yeah I was fine with sure Heather um it
wasn't a huge issue for me because the
comic also has violence and sex involved
it was a very gritty comic first time
that those kind of things are going to
be involved in this type of story but I
did find some of it especially that
scene you're referencing earlier in the
night owl owl
our movies album never been the bad
whatever it was just so ridiculous and
over-the-top hallelujah so wha
yeah ways of the music in that moment to
do like the Hallelujah song was just way
too much for me it was so over-the-top
and I it was funny but I don't know like
it was supposed to be funny i
shouldn't've been sitting there in
stitches being like okay didn't like man
she just needed this connection of human
connection is getting it but instead
you're like ha ha ha right oh yeah right
I was laughing and I want have been
outdoors and some of the violence is a
little bit over the top but it doesn't
bother me too much I mean the only time
where I felt like okay it was a little
bit and also sometimes during the jail
break scenic it's a little excessive you
know especially when the guy's arms are
getting some cut off you know things
like that I'm not I'm not prude but okay
we get it we get it I would argue
there's a difference between the movie
in the comic in the sense that with a
comic you can sit and read it for as
long as you want and put it down in a
movie you're sort of set with however
long they're young can you watch it yeah
so I understand if some people while
they're watching it think Oh the scenes
going on too long or like oh I'm seeing
too much and like with a comic you get
to decide when you're when you're done
with that moment right in a movie you're
it's your up to their will how long you
have to do it oh yeah well there's some
subtlety sometimes where it's almost
more gory for you to think about rather
than see it like it is the jail break
scene when were shot goes into the
bathroom after the that gangster gosh I
can't think of his name but he goes into
him
goes after him into the bathroom and all
you see is the blood trickle a lot of
glass away why do I just look like I
really idea what happened but that's
more interesting to me that Rorschach
cutting someone's arms off yet is not a
large man that amount of blood I want
open sir I have no idea yes
yes yes I will say on the issue of
sexual ization
of this movie so expected people in the
costume ridiculousness
that is my costuming news for the movie
and I will move on we're going to move
on to our final topic I know guys
there's a lot to talk about here so go
ahead and engage us in the comments
below
what we miss what you thought was good
and what you thought was bad but finally
we're going to discuss relating it to
the comics does it relate well should it
relate well difference in the ending
Porter do you want to kind of summarize
yours first
well I always I'm a huge you know I
always want the the movies sameer the
comics as best as they possibly can and
from what I've seen just flipping
through seem like a lot of the shots
mirrored the overall tone I'm not too
sure I know you said that they changed
the ending a lot and had I read the
comic had I been a fan of it I'm sure I
would have hated that because it's like
don't change the ending you change the
ending you change the way the characters
interact with each other and change the
tone of the film so I don't I don't like
that I think that they should have kept
the ending even though it sounded
completely ridiculous but so you think
that even if they sing wow it worked
well in graphic novel it probably won't
really well on screen you still think
they should go for it
or I mean at least I see how the ending
in the movie worked well for this you
know it seemed to fit the tone with the
Doomsday Clock and also their stuff and
Manhattan being overpowered and whatnot
but I feel like maybe at least test
footage audience you know whatever like
see how it actually looks instead of
just nope no tentacle monsters book so I
mean at least try at least try but if it
really just does not work I guess
changes out to where it's the best
possible but like I I would rather than
keep the original for as much of it as
possible okay Heather so this is
probably one of my biggest issues with
the movie in general in that it stays
true to the comic at times but then the
things that they change are almost
baffling what
why would you stay so true to it in
certain parts and then be like bring it
no ending her why why set it up though
why set it up to be exact exactly the
same shot-for-shot word for word
sometimes to then change other things
that seem pointless to change like I
didn't like that they changed the ending
I would I would rather see giant
tentacle squid monster right I would
because I do set it up well in the
graphic novel I know some people have
also said well they changed it because
it wouldn't translate well and you can't
really set that up but they set it up in
the comic there you can easily set it up
in the movie I just thought about this
probably pretty set it up well I mean
look at Hellboy you know it's fricking
tentacle monster I don't know I'm
like okay we have we've seen this right
it works I have a comic book movies let
people suspend their disbelief for this
world we already have a giant blue man
going to Mars why not why not I draw the
lines of Hama so I just feel like it was
strange the things that they chose to
change it was an odd compromise I feel
like between trying to stay true for the
fans but still having to be cool still
having a good yes still having to be a
blockbuster movie because there's so
many issues that they tapped on the
graphic novel that maybe a modder that a
ruby audience isn't going to be engaged
by are going to be put off by because it
is rather political and the movie did
keep some of that tone but also some of
it is lost because they needed to be
able to make it a blockbuster movie as
well it couldn't just be a direct
translation and I understand that it
can't be it's a movie you're going to
have to pick up game lore and things but
then change I don't even I don't even
know it baffles me that they just keep
it scene for scene otherwise and then
change other things such as don't seem
to make sense why they change those
specifically why yeah it was very
baffling to me and this is kind of
related to the comic as well I also had
a problem with the coloring of the movie
the movie itself is very gritty dark and
blue kind of hinted tinted blue a lot
tonight everybody was wrong but in the
graphic novel there's more vibrant
colored red today the colorist and the
artist do a great job of playing around
with that to tell the narrative visually
as well in the graphic novel and so I
felt like we were missing some of that
with the dark painted blue of of the
movie so it didn't that bothered me I
bet that's a nitpicky thing my crazy lod
bothersome but it's it and then I also
overall fed industry with the soundtrack
not just the hallelujah yeah oh yeah so
like bonus bonus track now I want to
thank super quick of the music the
soundtrack yes we were just jointed
because they started the movie with
those old classics which was kind of fun
I was like okay this is amusing this is
interesting and the way they're
introducing the characters it's really
cool yeah and then about some hour into
the movie they're like just kidding now
it's all like a Hollywood movie score
and then they brought it back
occasionally it's like remember when we
did this just kidding it's gone again
now it was just very awesome as you know
just jointed and sometimes then they
would bring back other classical pieces
of music not like rock music but other
pieces of classical music like during
the Vietnam scene when dr. Manhattan is
in Vietnam with the comedian and that
was maybe supposed to be a little bit
comical but it definitely made me laugh
so what doesn't so ridiculous what an
odd choice a piece like I don't know you
listening I don't remember the music at
all and I love like film scores and all
that stuff so as my esteemed colleague
Nick's that if you don't remember it
it's probably not that good all right
well on that note was Watchmen memorable
for you what did you think of the movie
we would love to hear from you in the
comments down below so make sure to let
us know I know it's a aidid debate
that's why we're here that's why we're
talking about it so let us know what you
think thanks again for liking this video
thanks again for going to Facebook and
liking our Facebook page we put
exclusive content up there every
Thursday
extra videos from you sometimes there's
too much to talk about in an episode and
we want to give you more we want to talk
about it more and so we go on Facebook
and put a little extra video up for you
every week sometimes with Cuba's hasn't
been free videos yet but no go like it
might be this week who knows this might
be the week we do and might be the time
so thanks for joining us Heather where
can we find you on social media you can
find me on Twitter at Heather Ruth or
instagram at Atrus and for directly find
you facebook.com slash awesome porter
and pork chop 0 to 8 9 twitter beautiful
and of course you can always find them
here on often comics you can find me on
a facebook facebook.com slash Ayanna
Wade I'm also on Twitter snapchat
Instagram come on all of them you all
know already so come and find me some
chat with me about this we're always up
for discussing into topics every week we
look awesome and that's why we're here
doing it so thanks again for watching
everyone from us here at awesome comics
we'll see you on the next space
[Music]
[Applause]